- You know, it's funny, usually
in a domestic defamation
dispute like this,
the internet has all kinds of opinions,
but they've been completely silent
about Johnny Depp and
Amber Heard, it's weird.
(intense music)
Oh, okay.
This is all incredibly crazy.
And this latest suit and countersuit
is already turning into a circus.
Of course, for Hollywood
celebrities leading public lives.
It seems like there's no such thing
as a truly private matter.
And this has certainly been
the case for Amber Heard
who has publicly accused
her ex-husband Johnny Depp
of subjecting her to years of
physical and emotional abuse
during their marriage
and Depp for his part
has vehemently denied the allegations,
accusing Heard of defaming
him with fabricated claims
while portraying Heard as the real abuser.
And while Heard has primarily
aired her grievances
to the media, Depp has
opted to take his fight
to the courtroom in both the
UK and the state of Virginia.
Now determining the truth of
domestic violence allegations
is invariably a challenging prospect.
As a result, the public's
response to these allegations
has been incredibly polarizing
with Heard and Depp having
their own supporters
and detractors alike.
So legal eagles,
let's talk about the Johnny
Depp Amber Heard saga,
we'll cover the facts leading
up to the decades long dispute
between the former celebrity couple,
review the multimillion
dollar defamation lawsuits
in the UK and the US that
have been brought as a result
for basically the same thing.
(upbeat music)
Now the former Hollywood couple's
Virginia courtroom
confrontation is the culmination
of 10 years of love, heartbreak
and abuse allegations
between the "Pirate of
the Caribbean" actor
and the "Justice League" actress.
Here is the timeline of how this feud left
from the tabloids to the courtroom.
Now in 2012, Johnny Depp and Amber Heard,
began dating following Depp's split
from his longtime partner,
French model actress, singer,
Vanessa Paradis.
Depp and Paradis dated for 14 years.
And they shared two children together.
In February of 2015 Depp and
Heard officially tied the knot.
But as quickly as the pair fell in love,
things fell apart just as swiftly.
On May 21st, 2016, the LAPD responded
to a Saturday night call in which Heard
alleged domestic abuse.
Law enforcement officials at the time
stated they found quote
no evidence of any crime
and Heard did not file any charges.
On May 23rd, 2016 Heard
officially filed for divorce
from Depp citing
irreconcilable differences.
Four days later, Heard
appeared in a Los Angeles court
with a bruised cheek
to request a temporary
restraining order against Depp.
In a sworn declaration Heard alleged
that her then husband 23 years her senior
had quote violently attacked her
and thrown a cellphone at
her face with extreme force.
Photographs submitted
to the court show Heard
with a large bruise on her face,
along with broken bottles, picture frames
and shattered glass on the floor.
Heard alleges that quote
during the entirety of our relationship,
Johnny has been verbally and
physically abusive end quote.
Heard further claimed that she quote
endured excessive, emotional,
verbal, and physical abuse,
which has included angry,
hostile, humiliating,
and threatening assaults to me,
whenever I questioned his
authority or disagreed with him.
Now in her filings Heard recounted
an alleged April 21st assault
wherein Depp allegedly came home drunk
as Heard's birthday party was ending,
through a champagne bottle
at a wall, grabbed her hair,
violently shoved her to the floor
and Heard also alluded to
quote one severe incident
in December, 2015 when I
truly feared for my life.
People magazine would
later publish a photo
purportedly from this incident.
In opposition to these
motions, Depp's lawyers
claimed the allegations were false
and accused Heard of quote attempting
to secure a premature financial resolution
by alleging abuse.
On May 27th of that year.
The judge granted Heard's
temporary restraining order
ordering Depp to stay
at least 100 yards away
and avoid all contact until
a June 17th follow up hearing
that would decide whether the
order should be made permanent
but hours before the scheduled hearing
Heard and Depp released a joint statement,
announcing that they had
resolved their dispute.
Quote our relationship
was intensely passionate
and at times volatile,
but always bound by love.
Neither party has made false
accusations for financial gain.
There was never any intent of
physical or emotional harm.
Now in August of 2016, Depp and Heard
reached a divorce settlement
with Heard allegedly pledging
to donate 7 million to the
American Civil Liberties Union
and the Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles.
In August of 2021, a New York judge,
partially granted Depp's
motion to force the ACLU
to produce documents to show
if she did in fact donate the $7 million,
a fact that remains contested by Depp.
And after the divorce was
finalized in January of 2017,
Depp's attorney Laura Wasser
released the following statement,
quote, we are pleased to
put this unpleasant chapter
in Mr. Depp and his
family's lives behind them
having his request for entry
of the dissolution of judgment
granted today made it a
particularly lucky Friday the 13th.
Now, while Depp's attorneys declared
their client's intention to
put this chapter behind him,
the British tabloids
would not extend Mr. Depp
such a courtesy, which takes
us to how the UK lawsuit
got filed.
Now, following the divorce,
both Heard and Depp
continued to pursue their
respective acting careers.
Heard reprised her role
as Mera from "Aquaman"
for Josh Whedon's
"Justice League" in 2017,
while Depp returned as
Captain Jack Sparrow
for the fifth "Pirate of
the Caribbean" installment.
But as Depp was preparing
to reprise his role
as the autonomous villain in JK Rowling's
"Fantastic Beasts The
Crimes of Grindelwald"
The Sun, a British tabloid
fired a shot across the pond
by rehashing Heard's abuse allegations.
On April 27th, 2018, The Sun
executive editor, Dan Wooten
published an article entitled, gone potty.
How can JK Rowling be genuinely happy
casting wife beater, Johnny Depp
in the new "Fantastic Beasts" film.
Writing that quote overwhelming evidence
was filed to show Johnny Depp
engaged in domestic violence
against his wife Amber Heard.
Wooten accused the "Harry Potter" author
of quote providing Depp
total rehabilitation
in the eyes of the movie
industry by allowing Depp to star
in the "Fantastic Beasts" sequel.
Now Depp's response to
the article was swift.
On June 1st, 2018 Depp
sued the parent company
that publishes The Sun
in England for libel
demanding a minimum of
$200,000 plus legal fees.
Depp's attorneys argued
the article defamed him
by presuming the actor was
guilty of domestic violence
against his former wife
highlighting the use of
the term wife beater.
Now Depp's counsel maintained
that these quote reputation destroying
and career ending allegations were untrue
and caused the actor quote serious harm,
the threshold standard
for defamation in England.
In its defense The Sun's
parent company argued
that there was sufficient evidence
to show that Depp was quote
a violent towards Miss Heard
on multiple occasions
during their relationship
making the term wife beater
an accurate statement.
And in support of its claims,
the company relied on 14 alleged
incidents of physical abuse
against Heard that purportedly occurred
between 2013 and 2016.
Though neither Depp nor
Heard were on trial.
The case was essentially a dress rehearsal
for the pair's Virginia defamation trial
with both Depp and Heard
giving live testimony
detailing an array of graphic allegations.
When Depp took the stand,
he acknowledged wide
ranging drug problems,
which he referred to as quote the monster,
but Depp accused Heard
of making up allegations
and insisting that he was
quote not a violent person,
especially with a woman,
a characterization that was
backed up in sworn statements
from former partners, Winona
Rider and Vanessa Paradis.
Depp portrayed Heard as the
aggressor in the relationship
accusing her of repeatedly belittling him
and frequently turning physically violent
during their tumultuous marriage
saying quote, it was sort of a rapid fire
sort of endless parade of insults.
Quote, you know, looking
at me like I was a fool
and I was having difficulty
in my mind, of course,
and in my heart, dealing
with that sort of barrage.
Depp further alleged that Heard
would sometimes strike out
in anger or frustration
and regarding an alleged
headbutting incident
in December of 2015 at his LA penthouse,
Depp testified, he was
trying to hold Heard back
from hitting him and their
foreheads collided by accident.
Depp also detailed a
purported March, 2015 argument
in Australia that led to part
of his finger being sliced off
due to a thrown vodka bottle.
Depp contended that Heard saw him drinking
for the first time in a while.
And she threw a bottle of vodka
that narrowly missed his head
before throwing a larger bottle
that did strike his head.
Photos provided by Depp's counsel
purported to show Depp
with a bloody finger
and a cigarette burn on his face.
For her part, Heard denied injuring Depp
contending that her ex
severed his own finger
during a drug and alcohol binge
after repeatedly smashing
a wall mounted phone
against the wall.
Heard testified that depth
fueled by drugs and alcohol
hit, slapped and shoved
Heard, pulling her hair
and threw bottles quote
like grenades at Heard
at various incidents
between 2013 and 2016.
On cross examination Heard
denied the characterization
of Depp's lawyers that she was the one
who struggled with drugs and alcohol,
that she was the one who abused him.
And that she was the one who
was controllingly manipulative,
not Depp.
Now under cross-examination Depp admitted,
it was possible that
he destroyed the phone
stating quote I remember
ripping the phone off the wall.
Depp also admitted
that he had previously
taken responsibility
for severing his finger
though Depp claimed
that he was only trying to protect Heard
when he had to tell the
production company the injury
prevented him from working on set.
And Depp also confirmed that
he wrote messages for Heard
in blood, paint and lipstick,
including quote I love you
and quote good luck,
which he did to indicate
he felt the relationship was over.
And in a trial that had the couple
airing out their dirty
laundry Depp also detailed
an alleged incident involving
literal dirty laundry.
Supposedly on the night
of Heard's birthday party
in April, 2016, Depp says he arrived late
due to a meeting he was attending.
Depp testified that Heard
was furious with him
hitting him multiple times
after the party ended,
before he left and spent
the night at another home.
Depp said that he planned to
retrieve items the next morning
after Heard left for Coachella,
but was told by someone at the
home who texted him a photo
not to return because
there was poop in the bed.
Quote, it was a photograph
of the bed, our bed,
and on my side of the bed
was human fecal matter.
So I understood why it wasn't
a good time to go down there.
He continued my initial
response to that was,
I mean, I laughed it was so
outside, it was so bizarre.
And so grotesque that I could only laugh.
Depp had previously claimed
in a written statement
that Heard or one of her
friends were the culprit
and alleged that Heard
had called this quote,
just a harmless prank.
But Depp said that incident
was when he knew their marriage
was over and a month later
Heard filed for divorce.
Heard has denied any
role in this poo demit
suggesting the story is fabricated
simply to humiliate her.
So yeah, the British trial
was incredibly colorful.
And after hearing all of the evidence,
the UK court sided with The Sun
and rejected Depp's libel claims.
In his November, 2020 opinion,
Justice Andrew Nichol
concluded that The Sun
had met its burden of proof
and that The Sun's allegations
that Depp engaged in unprovoked
attacks and violent conduct
against his then wife that
caused her to be in fear
for her life were true quote
on the balance of the probabilities,
meaning the abuse
allegations were more likely
than not to be true.
The Justice did not accept
Depp's characterization
of Heard as a gold digger who
had quote constructed a hoax
and as an insurance policy
in the event the marriage fell apart.
Among the incidents the judge
found to be substantially true
were the two events alluded
to in Heard's 2016 application
for domestic violence restraining order,
the May, 2016 assault with Depp's phone.
And the severe December, 2015 incident
where Depp allegedly
threw a decanter at Heard
in the penthouse, headbutted her
and pulled large chunks
of hair from her scalp
before an appearance on James Corden's
late late show.
And the justice did not find Depp's claim
that Heard was responsible
for severing his fingertip
to be credible.
And as for the poop in the bed incident,
well the judge blamed the dog
quote for what it's worth,
I consider it unlikely
that Ms Heard or one of
her friends was responsible
reasoning in part that
Depp was outta the house
at the time of the incident
and Heard was the one
likely to suffer from the effects.
The judge concluded quote,
it was therefore a
singularly ineffective means
for Ms Heard or one of her
friends to get back at Mr. Depp.
Your mileage may vary on that reasoning.
In response to the ruling
Depp's representative
stated they found the decision quote
as perverse as it is bewildering,
and immediately announced
their intention to appeal.
But in March of 2021
Depp's appeal was rejected.
And the court of appeals ruled
that the lower court case
was quote full and fair.
And the trial judge conclusions quote
have not been shown to
even arguably be initiated
by any error or approach a mistake of law.
And concluded the appeal has
no real prospect of success
and that there is no
other compelling reason
for it to be heard.
On appeal Depp's counsel had argued
they did not get a fair hearing.
And that Heard was an unreliable witness.
And as evidence of her
unreliability Depp's counsel
asserted that Heard has
not kept her promise
to donate her $7 million
divorce settlement to charity.
And the fallout from
Depp's spectacular defeat
was immediate.
Following the November
ruling Depp announced
he was leaving the
"Fantastic Beasts" franchise
after Warner Brother
requested his resignation.
And that takes us to the good old US of A
because what makes
Depp's defeat so notable
is that the odds of
prevailing on a libel claim
are much higher in England than in the US.
In England the party accused of defamation
has the burden of proving that their claim
is quote substantially true.
Now that's the opposite in the
US where the defamed person
has the burden of proving
that the libelist statements
are false.
Another reason US defamation
cases are hard to win
is that public figures like Depp
must prove the defamatory
statements were made
with actual malice meaning
that they were published
with knowledge of being false or reckless
regard for their truth or falsity.
Again, actual malice has nothing to do
with not liking a person, it
is an evidentiary standard,
and it's not particularly well named.
It's a legal term of art.
And even with these built in advantages,
Depp still lost twice in the UK.
In the face of Depp's double defeat
some have characterized
Depp's legal strategy
as a complete flop and remembered not only
have two British courts found
Heard's abuse allegations
to be substantially true,
but Depp's efforts have had
the unintended straizand effect
of amplifying these allegations.
After all, if not for
Depp's multiple lawsuits,
there would be no reason for this channel
to make a video on this controversy,
to the millions of legal
eagles subscribers.
It's a case of life
imitating art, I guess.
But Depp's defenders insisted
that the British trial
was not fairly decided that new evidence
has since come forward that
paints a different picture,
particularly with new audio
that purports to show Heard
admitting to abusing depth.
So after all of this, we find ourselves
back in American soil as Depp attempts,
another bite of the defamation apple
hoping this time he will be vindicated.
And particularly an issue
in the American trial
is an op-ed that Amber Heard published
on December 18th, 2018,
six months after Depp
filed the UK libel action
where she published
in the Washington Post,
an article entitled,
I spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's
wrath that has to change.
Heard wrote quote, like many women.
I had been harassed and sexually assaulted
by the time I was of college
age, but I kept quiet.
I did not expect filing
complaints to bring justice.
And I didn't see myself as a victim.
Then two years ago, I
became a public figure
representing domestic abuse.
And I felt the full force
of our culture's wrath
for women who speak out.
And in March, 2019, Depp
responded to the op-ed
by filing a $50 million defamation lawsuit
against his ex-wife
contending Heard's article
contained quote categorically
and demonstrably false claims
of domestic abuse.
Quote the op-ed depended
on the central premise
that Ms Heard was a domestic abuse victim
and that Mr. Depp perpetrated
domestic violence against her.
Depp's lawyers also wrote
in the complaint quote,
her allegations are part
of an elaborate hoax
to generate positive
publicity for Ms Heard in
and advance her career.
The complaint, which
again are just allegations
from one side charged that
Heard had incalculably damaged
the actor's reputation
and derailed his career
highlighting that Disney fired Depp
from the "Pirates of
the Caribbean" franchise
four days after the
publication of Heard's article.
And though the article does
not mention Depp by name
a party alleging defamation
need not be specifically named
so long as there are
enough identifying facts
of the person reading it
would reasonably understand
that the statements
refer to the plaintiff.
And in August of 2020 Heard counter sued
for $100 million arguing that
Depp's denial of the abuse
effectively accused Heard
of committing perjury
to obtain the 2016 domestic
violence restraining order,
which defamed her character.
Heard also accused Depp
of orchestrating an online
smear campaign against Heard
in violation of Virginia's
laws against online harassment.
Now, some of you might be
wondering why this case
is going to trial at all,
given that it appears to
have already been litigated
in another forum in the UK.
And there is a principle of
law that prevents re-litigation
of the same cause of
action in a second lawsuit
between the same parties.
It's called claim preclusion
also referred to as res judicata,
which is Latin for a matter decided
basically it's like double
jeopardy, but for civil suits.
And there's also issue
preclusion or collateral stoppel
preventing a party from
re-litigating an issue
once a court has already ruled on it.
Now Heard's lawyers tried to
get the US lawsuit thrown out
because of some of the claims
that were already decided
in the UK, but the
judge denied the motion.
Like most things in law, there
were arguments on both sides
of these issues.
And in particular, Amber
Heard was not a defendant
in the UK case, She was only a witness.
Depp was a party though.
And he appealed his case to
the highest court in the UK
and lost, but because Heard
wasn't a party in the UK case,
remember Depp sued The Sun
and The Sun's parent company.
And a few other reasons,
Amber Heard was not able to
benefit from claim preclusion
and res judicata to prevent Depp
from being able to sue in Virginia.
And then also American courts
reject foreign judgments
that don't live up to American
standards of free speech.
And there's a law the
securing the protection
of our enduring and established
constitutional heritage act
prevents US courts from enforcing
foreign defamation
judgments that don't comport
with first amendment protections.
So even if Depp had won his case
and then asked American courts
to recognize the judgment,
the court probably would
have rejected his lawsuit.
Of course, now Depp has a
second bite at the apple,
and if he wins, it would be really unusual
given his loss in a country
with a lower standard
for proving defamation.
But either way, it's entirely possible
that Johnny Depp's career
is over and the jury is out,
whether that's Amber Heard's fault or not,
but the point may not be
about winning a legal victory,
but about winning a PR victory
and rehabilitating Depp's image.
And it seems like he's made
some progress in that respect
though, the Virginia
trial has already turned
into a complete circus.
I'll have to do another video
summarizing all the craziness
that has already occurred,
including Heard's lawyer
objecting to himself
and Johnny Depp becoming
an expert on hearsay.
But if Johnny Depp wins either legally
or in the court of public opinion,
he should celebrate by
making himself a nice meal,
which he can do with
today's sponsor Hello Fresh.
Hello Fresh is a great way
to eat delicious fresh food
while still being healthy.
In fact, Hello Fresh has
a variety of calorie smart
and carb smart recipes,
as well as pescatarian and veggie options,
as well as a new Mediterranean line.
You can customize it how you'd like,
you can swap out proteins
or get premium top of the line versions.
Now I'm a do it yourself person.
And I have to say, I was
initially pretty skeptical
about Hello Fresh.
I'm a pretty good cook.
So I didn't really
think I needed the help,
but I actually love it.
And even for an experienced
cook Hello Fresh
delivers new ingredients and recipes
that I'd never try on my own.
Hello Fresh generally keeps
everyone's favorite meals
and then rotates new ones in all the time.
Most recently I've enjoyed
seasonal spring recipes
like sweet heat shrimp tempura bowls.
Try saying that one three times fast.
Garden spinach ricotta ravioli,
also a tongue twister
and one pod creamy
lemon dill chicken soup.
Now I don't know about you,
but I would never have
attempted those on my own,
especially just 'cause it's hard to say,
but honestly they're really delicious,
no matter how hard it is
to actually say the titles.
And in fact, I usually increase the size
of my Hello Fresh servings so
that I can enjoy the leftovers
for lunches and snacks later on.
And it's not just meals.
Hello Fresh's marketplace
features variety of add-ons
for breakfast, desserts
and seasonal snacks.
Again, huge time savings as well.
And of course everything was
delivered straight to my door.
So I didn't have to do any shopping.
The produce actually gets to you faster
than a grocery store.
So it arrives at peak freshness and flavor
and all this saves you
time because Hello Fresh
cuts out meal planning and prep.
So the recipes only take
20 to 30 minutes to cook
literally less time to cook
than it would normally take
to do the shopping for the meal.
And it's also really sustainable
since the ingredients are pre-portioned,
there's less prep and less food waste.
The packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable
or already recycled content.
And Hello Fresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25% lower
than that of meals made
from store bought groceries.
And it's 72% cheaper than
dining at a restaurant.
So if you'd like to try Hello
Fresh, and you really should,
you can go to hellofresh.com
and use the code legal eagle 16
for up to 16 free meals
and three surprise gifts.
Yes, you can actually get 16 free meals
and that includes free shipping.
All you have to do is click on the link
that's on screen right now.
So again for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts,
click on the link that's
on screen right now
and use the promo code legal
eagle 16 when you check out
plus clicking on the link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it,
click on this playlist
of my other videos.
So click on this link or
I'll see you in court.